[Music]
Marketing nobody likes it we download
blockers to avoid ads shame trailers
that misrepresent graphics and generally
be moaned the entire concept of hype
[Applause]
which exists in part thanks to carefully
crafted marketing materials but there
are exceptions that proof pre-release
promotions can do more than just sell a
product
Capcom's recent handling of Resident
Evil 7 is an amazing example they used
the game's marketing as a covert
storytelling opportunity we didn't know
it at the time but the beginning our
demo was in essence a narrative prologue
that allowed Capcom to set up and
subsequently undermine our expectations
sure they were ultimately just trying to
promote their game but in the process
they found a way to heighten and enrich
the tension in the final experience in
case you missed it the beginning our
teaser is unlike most MOS a standalone
experience rather than a slice of the
unfinished game it drops players into a
tightly contained section of a
dilapidated house and confronts them
with a few unnerving puzzles as they
work to escape the protagonist is never
identified but based on a couple of the
possible endings we know it's not
Resident Evil 7 star Ethan winters for
you are nothing just a man Capcom also
confirms beginning our takes place
before the main game which importantly
allows it to act as a framing device
when you first arrive at the Baker
compound as Ethan you walk through a
darkened room before emerging in an
eerily familiar corridor if you played
the teaser this moment instantly takes
on several new dimensions first
excitement is you realize you just
walked through a door that been close to
you for months just when you least
expected it the mystery is solved and
your curiosity rewarded but that feeling
is quickly overcome by another
realization holy I'm standing where two
guys were murdered what's about to
happen to me suddenly you have a whole
new reason to be afraid beyond how damn
creepy the house is on its own you know
there's some creepy guy with a shovel
somewhere and your character Ethan has
no idea at least not yet it's like
watching Jason Voorhees sneak up behind
an unsuspecting victim and when you find
this old newspaper in the next room
everything fully snaps into place the
protagonist of the beginning our demo
was one of these victims you were
playing as one of the people who
disappeared in any other game this
newspaper would be a relatively dry
piece of world building but here it's a
reminder of everything you went through
of how horrible ain't dangerous this
place really is thanks to the demo this
tiny piece of exposition comes to life
and becomes personal
but wait there's more as a sort of bonus
to these bigger revelations Resident
Evil 7 also includes a bunch of smaller
details that connect the full game back
to the demo for example you stumble
across a van that clearly belongs to the
ill-fated film crew featured in the
teasers VHS flashback make sure the
sound is right this time I don't want a
repeat of Amarillo years ago you also
find a particularly infamous digit later
in the game and here a line of dialogue
that subtly confirms the timeline
collectively these details are more than
just cool tie-ins they actively enhance
the tension by making the world feel
more believable the beginning our teaser
isn't the only example of a creative
pre-release demo but it's an especially
good one because it functions almost as
a concise self-contained prequel even if
it is just a marketing tour this really
speaks to some creative work by Capcom
but it also demonstrates the power of
thoughtful storytelling this all works
because it gets in your head plays on
your fears and enhances your
understanding of the world and through
that understanding you get immersion
excitement and a whole new layer of fear
it's okay it's me we know you didn't
mean to hurt me have done that if you
liked this video why not check out some
other fine gamespot products like our
official Resident Evil 7 review or our
reviving Resident Evil series which
takes an in-depth look at the
development of the game and for those of
you watching on youtube be sure to
subscribe for more hot content in the
future